le temps des applaudissements est révolu
plus que de belles paroles et de gestes
symboliques le personnel soignant
réclament plus de moyens c'est le cas
déjà depuis 14 mois de grèves de
manifestations et une crise sanitaire
qui a fait près de trente mille morts en
france les politiques d'austérité menées
par les différents gouvernements
successifs avant la crise sanitaire et
les non prise en compte de ce
gouvernement en matière de santé et
d'action sociale ont généré des carences
en matière de prise en charge qui se
sont accentuées pendant la pandémie due
qu'aux vite 19 un retour à la normale
est inenvisageable pour les usagers ce
n'est plus le temps d'applaudir les
soignants mais de soutenir nos
revendications qui sont aussi les vôtres
nous le répétons les professionnels ne
se contenteront plus de belles promesses
et de demi mesure une colère qui doit
être de nouveau exprimé ce mardi aux
quatre coins de la france une
mobilisation qui s'annonce massive et
qui intervient en plein milieu du ségur
de la santé lancée par l'exécutif le 25
mai est censé aboutir d'ici à mi juillet
dans son allocution du 14 juin
emmanuel macron a tenté de rassurer le
président de la république a promis de
mieux faire grâce à l'engagement
exceptionnel de nos soignants et de
toutes les équipes
l'ensemble des malades qui en avait
besoin ont pu être prises en charge à
l'hôpital ou dans la médecine de ville
cette reconstruction doit aussi être
social et solidaire une relance par la
santé comme nous avons commencé à le
faire avec la négociation du ségur qui
non seulement revalorisera les
personnels soignants mais permettra de
transformer l'hôpital comme la médecine
de ville par des investissements
nouveaux et une organisation plus
efficace et préventive une relance
solidaire qui permettra de mieux
protéger nos aînés une grande réforme de
l'hôpital qui est loin de satisfaire les
syndicats
plusieurs d'entre eux dénoncent une
imposture
contrairement à ce que dit le
gouvernement
non l'hôpital n'a pas su faire face des
personnes âgées atteintes du coc vite 19
n'ont pas pu être prises en charge à
cause du manque de lits en réanimation
ce n'est pas ce qu'on veut le ségur de
la santé ne doit pas est une imposture
une pure opération de communication une
montagne qui n'accoucherait que d'une
souris
le jour d'après ne sera pas le retour au
jour d'avant début de réponse du
gouvernement avec la prime qu'ovide de
1000 à 1500 euros
elle est destinée au personnel ayant
exercé entre le 1er et le 30 avril
objectif de cette prime défiscaliser
d'après le ministère de la santé
valoriser l'engagement sans faille des
personnels hospitaliers et des ehpad
pendant cette crise sanitaire
mais pour le personnel soignant auquel
le gouvernement a prévu de rendre
hommage le 14 juillet alors de la fête
nationale c'est loin d'être suffisant
première revendication peut être la plus
importante l'augmentation des salaires
les syndicats réclament en effet 300
euros de plus par mois pour s'aligner
sur la moyenne européenne
autre revendication des créations de
postes et l'annulation des suppressions
de lits 17500 religion en effet disparu
au cours des six dernières années